quand on est très sellem qu'on est au
top ou en bas il ya des mandales et on
est totalement perdue on fait plus à
quoi se raccrocher le dis à chaque fois
il faut un gros mental c'était une foire
au mental est bien entouré oui moi je
vous dis moi j'ai très mal j'ai pas j'ai
pas été au bout de deux 2 ça parce que
j'ai des enfants et que c'est très
pensée arabe a aimée quand j'étais
vraiment au fond au fond au fond des
chiottes et que on vous rajoute du caca
par dessus et qui renferme mêmes et
c'est ça et que l'on sait plus comment
faire que vous êtes assignés à gauche à
droite qu'on voulait zoom est en prison
donc pas payer une pension alimentaire
etc au bout d'un moment vous dites égal
à quoi bon continuer à se battre et très
sérieusement si si si si dans leur
vessie part je vous explique a bien su
un divorce quand tu es connu tu prends
tu prends bien plus cher que quand tu es
un inconnu et
honnêtement parfois la pression elle est
trop forte alors je veux pas me plaindre
il y avait plein de fois pour plein de
gens mais c'est vrai que parfois on a on
se dit où je vais est-ce que forcément
on est inconnu vous pouviez pas faire
autre chose aussi c'est ça d'abord c'est
compliqué moi vous dire que je pouvais
faire serveurs distants est d'accord
avec mon tort a pas mais mais mais c'est
vrai que tu as plus de boulot tu es chez
toi on t'a pris ta maison tendue des
avances à sa devient assad est un peu
lourd et effectivement tu vas voir à
quoi bon continuer après on pense aux
enfants et en sort et on saura se ravise
et on est bon mais a beaucoup de talent
mais parfois c'est long à remonter quand
même donc moi je comprends très bien et
c'est pas une question 2 et c'est une
question de mal-être en fait le tuc en
fait je le sais de regarder ce que tu
étais tu es au top on te voit on te voit
plus au top et se et le regard des
autres fait que tu te sens très mal et
ça devient très compliqué à assumer et à
vivre et au sens à vivre à supporter
cela retient plus est effectivement
super prisé dans ces moments là
effectivement on pense au pire après bon
bah alors dans le cadre vous aviez
vraiment pensé vous allez dire vous
mettre une balle dans la tête oui pascal
bats je n'ai pas fait parce qu'encore
une fois j'ai des enfants mais mais
effectivement il ya deux trois fois il
ya deux trois nuits ou ours dit [ __ ]
je vais je ne fais pas cette connerie
parce que ça devient très compliqué et
d'en cas de miss usa quand elle se
balance d'un immeuble de manhattan c'est
qu'elle en a vraiment ras le bol parce
que elle va au bout quand on balance de
la fête c'est qu'on s'éclate vraiment on
veut aller au bout après est-ce que
c'est envoyer un signal d'alarmé ce
qu'on est ce qu'on va peut-être se faire
plein tu vas me dire mais parfois je
vous jure et c'est valable pour les gens
connus ou inconnus mais quand il ya plus
d quand tu penses que tu as plus d'issue
et que le regard des autres devient une
souffrance est tellement le tien fait
que le regard qu'on porte sur toi est
devenu insupportable et sa foi c'est
vrai tu sais quoi mais non mais c'est
voilà vous étiez là vous et bien même
même aux enfants ils arrivent aux voix
en peignoir comme une mère kabyle locke
avec des yeux comme ça vous êtes
dépressif tout devient compliqué on voit
bien qu'on renvoie une image de merde et
à ce moment là il faut il faut il faut
il faut il faut il faut un peu il faut
effectivement je pense un gros mental
que je pense avoir parce que j'ai pas
fait cette connerie c'est trop monté
d'ailleurs magenta c'est un truc de fou
mais parce que effectivement parce que
j'ai eu après j'ai de la chance de
manger j'ai eu quand même des gens qui
étaient là il ya deux trois personnes
qui étaient là mais on et puis surtout
on pense aux enfants et on ne t'a pas de
faire ça c'est trop facile mais des fois
je vous le chanterai compliqué et dans
ces métiers où on est très connu et dans
ces métiers on est très connu et il ya
ceux qui sont monté tellement haut que
ça devient insupportable il faut
l'entendre que c'est de plus ça peut
être insupportable quand arrive à un tel
niveau de vie en fait tu ne vois plus de
100 t il le regard des autres pareils
c'est tellement haut que le regard des
autres tintin supporte et à ce moment là
tu dis j'en ai marre et ça arrive à des
gens qui sont au top et qui suscite
quand jane il n'était arrivé tellement
haut à 28 ans ouvertement que ça devient
insupportable restait s'est paraît il et
il est mort au top donc faut pas penser
que c'est l'oseille c'est là le regard
et la pression même pas la pression
l'amour ou la haine des autres dans
leurs yeux ça devient invivable et ça
pour le coup on peut l'entendre et c'est
pas une question d'oreille c'est une
question de 2,2 de survie voilà